six ans plus tard nous n'avons eu aucune
difficulté à retrouver ici noé sa
famille il habite toujours à salt lake
city
dans ce petit pavillon hlm et c'est en
anglais qu elle nous accueille
bonjour comment ça va bonjour comment
allez vous ça fait plaisir de vous
revoir ça me fait plaisir moi aussi
bienvenue chez moi ici nous a bien
changé
elle n'est plus la femme frêle que nous
avions rencontrés dans les camps
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ma maison américaine
regardez comme elle est grande et toutes
les choses qu'on peut y trouver c'est
beau regardez ma télé j'ai aussi un
lecteur de cassettes et de dvd pour la
visite isnino a déjà abandonné l'anglais
encore difficile à maîtriser
elle qui a vécu dans une hutte en terre
sans eau ni électricité
elles mesurent aujourd'hui le chemin
parcouru avant d'arriver ici
elle a dû tout apprendre
bon maintenant on va voir autre chose
ce machin là ça sert à quoi ça c'est ce
qu'on appelle une gazinière
aux etats unis les gens ne consume à la
nourriture avec du bois ou avec du
charbon de bois
là bas on fait la cuisine avec du gazon
casse chinois alors 35 ans elle découvre
les accessoires de la vie occidental et
ce ne sera pas sans surprise
arrivé en amérique premier repas et
premier incident par erreur elle vient
d'enclencher sans le savoir
le broyeur automatique de l'évier
[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui se passe
il ya quelque chose qui tourne
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh je me souviens du broyeur
on a cru que la maison allait
s'effondrer aujourd'hui je n'ai plus
peur de rien je sais tout utilisé voici
mon réfrigérateur est au dessus regardez
c'est génial il y à un congélateur
je peux garder des aliments longtemps
l'âge et de la viande est un poulet et
dans le frigo
il ya des jus des pâtes des tomates tout
plein de choses que j'aurais jamais
imaginé posséder un jour
[Musique]
non
moi
[Musique]
tous ces appareils qui l'entourent
continue d'émerveiller isnino à
commencer par cette machine à laver
ça reste une grande surprise de voir
toutes ces machines le plus beau c'est
que je n'ai plus besoin d'aller chercher
de l'eau je ne sais pas d'où elle vient
cette eau mais la rive en permanence et
elle est toujours propre
je n'imaginais pas qu'une machine puisse
laver le linge à ma place entre temps la
famille d'ici ne nous a rejoint
nous leur proposons alors de visionner
le reportage que nous leur avions
consacré il ya six ans ils n'ont jamais
revu d'image de cette époque
[Musique]
vas-y mais le film ils veulent se voir
re découvrir leur visage avant que leur
vie ne bascule c'était il ya six ans un
autre temps un autre monde
[Musique]
vol american airlines 115 dans cet avion
à destination de salt lake city
une famille de réfugiés somaliens
suspendu entre deux mondes
la petite fille aux tresses scénario
elle a aujourd'hui 15 ans âge avait des
grandes oreilles
à ses côtés sa petite soeur awa elle a
pris quelques kilos en six ans la jeune
fille qui regarde par le hublot ses
tâches à elle est aujourd'hui marié à
hussein un bon tout qu'elle a connu dans
le camp de kakuma ils ont eu deux
enfants tout donner en amérique mais
passée la surprise de se revoir ce sont
les mauvais souvenirs qui vont refaire
surface
la case de mukhtar il y vit depuis deux
ans avec sa famille ni snow et leurs
huit enfants dans deux jours ils vont
définitivement quitter le camp et
s'envoler pour l'amérique
c'est qui ces gens dans le film c'est
nous ces serres kakuma oui c'est là
qu'on guette en mouraient de faim là bas
[Musique]
ça c'est ça la sallaz que l'on voit ici
dans les bras disent ni nos marchés à
peine quand il a quitté l'afrique il
n'en n'a bien sûr aucun sourire
regarde comme s'ils étaient maigres
avant d'arriver en amérique
[Musique]
c'est ça la guerre maman c'est quand on
doit se laver et cuisiner avec de l'eau
sale quand je vois ça ça me donne envie
de vomir
ici nos a vécu de telles horreurs qu'à
voir sa famille autour d'elle suffit à
la rendre heureuse
seul ombre au tableau l'absence de son
mari décédé il ya deux ans nous sommes
au cimetière de redwood suite carré
musulman
c'est ici que mouctar son mari est
enterré malade du coeur
il n'aura vécu que quatre ans en
amérique le pays dont il avait rêvé
toute sa vie son coeur a fini par lâcher
les mais vivre ici pour lui l'amérique
c'était la liberté
elles étaient soignés gratuitement ici
les gens l'aider elle était vraiment
heureux pour le père du petit salle à
l'amérique c'était le rêve d'une vie
meilleure
une vie où il pourrai manger à sa faim à
se déplacer sans craindre la guerre et
surtout donner une éducation à ses
enfants
[Musique]
je crois qu'il serait très fier de moi
lorsqu'il m'a toujours demandé de bien
travailler à l'école et de me comporter
décemment en me tenant à l'écart des
problèmes s'il était parmi nous il
serait très fier de moi
veuve et son travail depuis deux ans ici
nino se débrouiller avec les aides de
l'état
350 euros par mois pour nourrir ses
quatre enfants
[Musique]
le lendemain matin isnino va nous faire
une surprise elle veut nous montrer
qu'elle a réussi à dompter ce qui
effraie le plus tous les bantous
d'amérique la voiture
m
j'ai mis trois ans à réussir à conduire
une voiture et a passé mon permis
au début j'étais terrorisée j'ai eu
trois accidents dès la première semaine
ici ne nous emmène au supermarché nous
allons retrouver le seul de ces enfants
qui n'habitent plus chez elle son fils
aîné hassan le voici lors de son arrivée
en amérique
entourée de sa famille hasan le petit
enfant timide a alors 12 ans et
s'émerveillent devant tout ce qu'il
découvre aujourd'hui le voici
bonjour mon fils comment tu vas aller
vraiment le contact et distant ici nos
est resté trop africaine à son goût il
ne la voit pratiquement plus que pour
faire les courses
le rayon fruits et légumes est ignorée
hassan et sa maman se dirige directement
au rayon des surgelés
depuis six ans les enfants disent nino
ne mange plus que ça
français le fromage sa vérifier que ça q
bien au four micro ondes
on est en amérique maintenant il aime
tout ce qui vient d'ici
hassan a aujourd'hui 18 ans est devenu
un américain plus vrai que nature
comment va la vie pour toi en amérique
il ya du bon et du moins bon c'est à
dire tu peux préciser la bonne chose
c'est la liberté
les mauvais côtés
c'est qu'ici tu dois payer pour tous un
jour tu reçois ta paye et la main
terminé on sent hassan gênés en présence
de sa mère il ne veut pas nous parler
davantage il est devenu un mauvais
garçon en amérique il refuse m'écoutait
j'essaie de le convaincre de faire le
bien je lui parle tous les jours je fais
ce que je peux mais l'agent peut alors
pour nous parler de sa vie américaine
hassan va accepter de nous recevoir chez
lui
[Musique]
oh
mon
[Musique]
dans le pavillon d'hassan une dizaine de
jeunes à la dérive fume de l'herbe toute
la journée à l'exception d'un américain
et d'une polynésienne ce sont tous des
jeunes réfugiés bantous complètement
déboussolé après six ans de vie en
amérique chef de gang
voilà ce qu'est devenu hassan le fils 10
nino l'enfant timide que nous avions
quitté il ya six ans s'est vite retrouvé
dans la rue à vendre du crack
sophie sa petite amie polynésienne lui
ramène aussi de l'argent en faisant des
strip tease dans des chambres d'hôtel à
sanaa fait de la délinquance
son rêve américain je ne pensais même
pas que ce genre de vie existent et moi
j'ai grandi en afrique avec mes frères
quand on est arrivé ici on a commencé
avec la tête dans la merde on allait de
marché en marché pour piquer la
nourriture lui il ne pensait qu'à manger
moi je ne pensais qu'à devenir une star
du ciné je rentrais dans les cinémas et
je me planquer au fond de la salle
j'imagine ce qu'on était un gars cool
est devenu c'est un super changement
moi
la vie et folie si tu me filme la vie
est folle
j'aime bien l'amérique mais je n'ai pas
encore vu le rêve américain
j'aime l'amérique mais je la comprends
pas ici j'ai l'impression de réfléchir à
l'envers je dois vivre au jour le jour
membres pour incarner le rêve américain
hamadi lui veut devenir un athlète
bodybuildé ça me fait mal ça fait trois
jours que je peux plus dormir je me sens
américain les muscles sont bien là mais
le plus visibles sur le corps dame a dit
ce sont encore ces taches noires sur la
poitrine et sur le dos des impacts de
balles 25 en tout 25 stigmates de sa vie
passée dans l'enfer de la guerre j'avais
cinq ans quand on m'a tiré dessus
j'y repense parfois je veux pas y
repensez à chaque fois que j'y repense
je fais des cauchemars terrible je peux
plus dormir alors tu vois je veux plus y
penser on vient du plus profond de la
jungle de la honte sur les pas tu me
comprends mais qu on avait que deux
trucs à ce mettre un tee shirt un short
et nos jambes pour s'enfuir
tu vois ce que je veux dire la loi la
basse et tu cours tu meurs
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ils ont reçu une importante
livraison de crack
il prépare deux petites doses 20 dollars
pièce les filles sont chargés de la
vente sur le trottoir manas étaient tous
but en 15 minutes
chèvre d'or l'argent désinhibés par
l'alcool et les drogues hassan veut nous
impressionner davantage c'est ainsi que
l'arm tomber dans cette vie trois ans
après son arrivée en amérique
hassan a déjà passé deux ans en prison
pour attaques à main armée il en est
sorti le mois passé
si on t'arrête tu vas être renvoyé dans
son pays sa t'inquiète pas non qu'est ce
qui va se passer si tu est renvoyé je
vais continuer à me faire de l'argent là
bas coûts car partout où il ya des
hommes de la drogue
tu vois ce que je veux dire en attendant
que la police n'arrête les affaires
continuent hassan et ses potes sont sur
le point d'acheter une maison et deux
voitures avec l'argent de leurs petites
entreprises sophie j'ai la drogue et mes
chaussures
on y va
regarde là j'ai 200 $ de crack et quand
je reviendrai j'aurais 200 dollars cash
dans une main et un sac de nourriture
dans l'autre tu peux parier là-dessus ça
les bébés embrasse moi j'étais hassan
n'est pas un cas isolé au sein de la
jeunesse bon tout en amérique leurs
différences culturelles et leur retard
dans l'éducation leur interdit l'accès à
une vie confortable
résultat en six ans 80% des jeunes vont
tous se sont tournés vers les gangs pour
réussir un problème que tente de prendre
à bras le corps hussein legendre 10 nino
on va vers l'est
je vais vous montrer la nouvelle
génération des bantous qui ont créé une
équipe de football on a environ une
centaine de jeunes qui jouent au foot
avec certains d'entre eux commencent à
bien s'en sortir mais pour d'autres
c'est encore la galère
anne pour tenter d'occuper ces ados et
les détourner des gangs
hussein a créé ce club de foot ici tous
les joueurs sont des réfugiés bantous en
mal d'adaptation
une fois la partie terminée hussein a
établi un rituel
les jeunes doivent se réunir pour faire
le point sur leur vie et parler de leurs
difficultés
bon les gars je compte sur vous pour que
tous ceux qui souffrent dans notre
communauté viennent nous rejoindre et
joue avec nous les prochains week-ends
je voudrais savoir comment vous allez
aujourd'hui si vous vous en sortez avec
votre vie américaine venir en amérique
c'était comme un rêve qui devient
réalité
on s'est dit qu'on pouvait tout faire
on était comme des chiens fous en
liberté mais 99 % des jeunes qui sont
ici ont déjà eu de gros ennuis
la majorité de nos problèmes viennent de
notre manque d'éducation une autre et on
en est conscient on s'améliore on
s'adapte au mieux mais jamais on ne
pourra rattraper les gens qui sont nés
ici quand l'un d'entre nous meurent ici
tu dois acheter ta place au cimetière
non je ne comprends pas ça en afrique tu
creuse un trou où tu veux et c'est tout
pourquoi faut-il acheter la terre où on
enterre pourquoi est-ce qu'un américain
pourrait répondre à ça dès que je serai
américain je me barre d'ici qui
souhaitent retourner en afrique
et qui souhaite y retourner
définitivement à ne pas définitivement
pas si si si si moi je pars et je ne
reviendrai plus jamais en amérique après
six ans aux états unis
la moitié de ces jeunes ne voient déjà
pu l'amérique comme une solution mais
bien comme un problème
hussein a peur que ses propres enfants
connaissent le même sort il nous reçoit
chez lui pour nous présenter les deux
enfants qu'il a eus avec achat la fidh
isnino
des enfants qui sont nés ici et qui
d'après la loi sont donc américain
regardez ça c'est le document qui prouve
qu'abdelkader et américains et il a une
date de naissance 15 mai 2006 un petit
détail qui fait toute la différence
en somalie les bantous n'avait aucun
papier et pas de date de naissance à
chaque connaît désormais l'âge de ses
enfants alors qu'elle ne connaît pas le
sien mon rêve c'était d'avoir des
enfants en amérique pour qu'ils soient
américains et qu'ils soient protégés des
horreurs que j'ai connu lorsqu'un chat
est arrivé en amérique
l'administration lui a donné une date de
naissance et le 1er janvier 1985 et pour
faire simple tout les bantous arrivé en
amérique sont dorénavant née un 1er
janvier pour éviter que leurs enfants ne
dérivent dans la violence des gangs du
sénat achats ont imaginé une solution
ils ont demandé à leurs familles restées
en somalie de se filmer et de leur
envoyer des cassettes
c'est ça que je montre à mes enfants ça
les surprend je leur dis que c'est ça la
vie que nous avions en afrique et je
leur demande s'ils voudraient aller
vivre là bas ils disent non regardez
c'était notre salle de prière regardez
ils ont tout détruit
ce sont les chevaliers du diable qui ont
fait ça ils ont pris des meubles
ils ont volé nos coraux ils ont même
brûlé notre toit pas certain que la
méthode fonctionne sur des petits de 2
et 3 ans mais hussein a trop souffert
pour imaginer que ces enfants ne
réussissent pas leur vie en amérique
je me souviens du jour où ils ont tué
mon voisin c'était devant mes yeux il
essayait de protéger sa femme qui allait
se faire violer alors ils l'ont abattu
d'autres ont été égorgés comme des
animaux
il ya des tas de choses que je n'ose
même pas vous raconter sur la somalie
ceux qui ont échappé à cette guerre ont
dû tout apprendre pour venir en amérique
à commencer par la langue dans les camps
de réfugiés
des ong avaient organisé des cours
d'anglais pour ses manteaux qui n'avait
jamais mis les pieds dans une salle de
classe à toi ahmed est un garçon ahmed
est un garçon fait main est une fille
fat mike duffy
c'est une c'est une barre son petit fils
une fille
six ans après la grande majorité d'entre
eux ne parlent toujours pas l'anglais
c'est le cas à d'haussmann 42 ans il est
toujours en galère pour lui l'anglais
reste une langue étrangère alors
aujourd'hui il se rend chez un ami pour
prendre des leçons
allez ousmane assieds toi comme la
plupart des bons tout en somalie
haussmann et l esclave d'un propriétaire
terrien dès l'âge de 5 ans il a
travaillé la terre et n'a jamais pu
apprendre à lire ou à écrire mon premier
problème c'est que je ne parle toujours
pas l'anglais je veux apprendre pour
obtenir mon passeport américain et
pouvoir enfin voyager aller en afrique
voir ma famille car je n'ai personne ici
ils sont tous restés dans les camps
d'assez devenir américain il faut que tu
parles et lisent l'anglais mais il faut
aussi que tu connaisse l'histoire et la
politique de ce pays
connaître les sénateurs les états les
lois qui nous gouvernent
osman devient étudiant pour la première
fois de sa vie à l'âge de 42 ans
c'est l'endroit où vit le président des
états unis la maison blanche
ouais maison blanche désormais il va
apprendre l'anglais en répétant
minutieusement les réponses qui lui
permettront un jour de devenir citoyen
américain
les citoyens américains ont le droit de
voter
ce sont eux qui élisent le président des
états unis tu comprends ça il se plie
parle anglais un peu un peu c'est bien
continuer mon gardien
[Musique]
osman travaille désormais dont le plus
bel hôtel de la ville ici il est un
employé heureux et modèles depuis
bientôt quatre ans vous avez vu comme
c'est beau ici et bien c'est là que je
travaille sont america lui c'est 7
dollars de l'heure pour travailler dans
les sous sols c'est la mairie qui si
celui qui ne travaille pas ne peut même
pas avoir douté
voilà ce que je fais en amérique je lave
la vaisselle des riches mais je vais
vous montrer quelque chose de génial
regardez regardez ce lave-vaisselle
il ne s'arrête jamais tourné et il fait
tout seul
bienvenue en amérique
si osman a le sourire c'est qu'il
revient de loin
arrivé en amérique ne comprenant rien à
l'argent il se couvre de dettes et finit
à la rue ancien sdf
il pose un regard critique sur le monde
qui l'entourent ici il faut être sérieux
et travailler sans cesse vous ne restez
pas le coran vous ne citez pas les
prophètes
c'est à ça que ressemble la fin du monde
mais c'est mieux que d'être assis dans
un camp à attendre l'aide et des nations
unies une fois quitté l'hôtel pour
arrondir ses fins de mois
osman utilise un vieux savoir ancestral
la culture bantou utilise la magie pour
résoudre bien des problèmes lors de
notre premier reportage nous avions
assisté à cette danse censé protéger
ceux qui partaient pour l'amérique
[Applaudissements]
osman entretient toujours se savoir
bonjour comment tu vas ça va entre je
t'attendais à l'été chaussures on va
commencer sauvegarde
je me sens pas très bien depuis une
semaine j'ai des maux de tête et des
douleurs un peu partout dans le corps
osman le médecin africain des bantous
d'amérique est considéré par ses
patients comme un magicien capable de
les soigner
bien mieux que les médecins américains
ces termes là on l'appelle dujos ça sert
à soigner les douleurs aux jambes
oui et à l'abdomen je vais le faire
transpirer alors il sera sur la voie de
la guérison
avant de commencer le traitement
je dois vous dire qu'on ne pratique
cette médecine qu'entre nous en amérique
je ne peux pas dire que je suis médecin
ici pour être médecin il faut une
licence
j'utilise cette médecine que sur des
gens qui y croire car il n'y a que de
cette façon que ça fonctionne s'il aide
moi à faire en sorte que cet homme aille
mieux
les livres le de sa douleur j'ai besoin
que tu lui envoies un signe de guérison
dans les 48 heures cet homme doit
retourner au travail
voilà ce que le docteur somaliens te
demande allez c'est fini
lève-toi et tire-toi la guérison a
commencé le patient se dit soulagé mais
haussmann lui est lucide son arrivée en
amérique lui a fait changer d'avis sur
ces pratiques ancestrales et il sait que
la médecine bantous vit ses derniers
instants en amérique
je suis le dernier des médecins
somalienne chez nous on n'avait rien
pour se soigner alors nos ancêtres ont
inventé cette médecine ça me permet
d'aider mes frères qui n'ont pas la
sécurité sociale
j'aimerais que mes enfants aussi il
soigne les bantous mais pas comme moi
que je veux qu'ils apprennent la
médecine à mairie
c'est comme ça qu'ils pourront faire le
bien autour d'auch
retour chez ninon ce soir aidé de sa
fille narnia elle s'affaire en cuisine
elles attendent des invités au menu
pizza au micro-ondes poulets frits
spaghetti et chips un repas spécial
fêtes
car pour la première fois hassan vient
lui présenter sa copine strip teaseuse
bonsoir
comment ça va je suis vraiment contente
de vous rencontrer
allez vous asseoir je vous en prie
asseyez vous asseyez vous je vous
prépare à manger isnino a fait un effort
mais la présence de cette jeune femme
semble dur à avaler
pendant le repas l'ambiance est glaciale
seule la console de jeu du petit ça la
brise le silence
hasan était pourtant venu faire une
annonce à sa mère sophie sa fiancée est
enceinte
ils attendent un enfant pour la fin de
l'été
vu l'ambiance ils n'oseront pas en
parler
[Musique]
après cinq minutes sans avoir dit un mot
hassan et sa fiancée s'en vont vous ne
restez pas vous n'avez rien mangé on va
finir à la maison maman attend au moins
que je te donne un fruit je vais devoir
finir mais pas sans vous alors au revoir
content de vous avoir connu je la trouve
pas bien cette fille
franchement c'est pas possible mais
pourquoi elle vient chez moi tout nu
comment veux tu que je la trouve bien
ici nos et désespéré par la vie que mène
son fils et elle met de l'argent de côté
pour essayer de le sauver à sa manière
dès que j'aurai à s'économiser
je le renvoie en afrique et là bas je le
mari à ma cousine est ce le seul moyen
de le sauver
six ans après leur arrivée isnino et sa
famille ont bien du mal à trouver leur
place dans ce pays où tout leur semble
est pourtant possible
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]